marc on était jeunes ce que ce n'était
pas de parler avec nous le serons torse
les politiques qui était paul rose
pour certains il était un terroriste
pour d'autres un héros après la mort de
son père son fils a voulu faire un
documentaire sur son histoire
je voulais comprendre qu est ce qui a
amené mon père mon oncle a posé des
gestes aussi grave
[ __ ] à la main en plein parce qu'ils
méritent l'aigle dans son film baptisé
baies roses félix rose retrace
l'évolution de la pensée politique de la
famille rose élevé dans le quasi
bidonville de veja quartier situé en
banlieue sud de montréal paul et jacques
rose rêvait de justice sociale il faut
que nous nous permettons conteste c'est
qu'on est content de mon père à la base
d'un militant c'est vraiment un militant
lui avait été très marqué par des gens
quartier la pauvreté et pour lui on est
des années 60 mais l'effervescence
nationale pour lui la question nationale
l'indépendance québec c'est une façon de
régler la question sociale les
injustices sociales basket on est dans
une époque où les francophones
travaillaient majoritairement dans des
usines et moyens démocratiques étaient
bloqués on en est arrivé à la conclusion
qu'il fallait lors de la crise d'octobre
de 1970
les frères aux faisait partie de la
cellule chénier du front de libération
du québec paul rose a été condamné pour
l'enlèvement et le meurtre du vice
premier ministre du québec pierre
laporte recherche paul rose
je voulais pas en faire des héros vous
l'avez juste présenter les personnes là
pourquoi la démarche puis je voulais pas
banaliser la gravité des gestes parce
qu'il ya quand même eu mort d'hommes
puis loin de moi l'idée de banaliser ou
d'excusé la mort de pierre laporte en la
dre en tant qu'événement fruit de huit
ans de travail
les roses a été réalisé à partir des
images d archives inédites et grâce à
une cinquantaine de témoignages pour une
rare fois en 40 ans on entend la version
de jacques rose présent lors du meurtre
de pierre laporte est condamné pour
complicité après les faits on n'avait
qu'une api
c'est on va les responsables locaux
boîte
le rapport qui n'a bizarrement c'est la
première fois qu'elle joue krups nous
raconte sa vie je trouve qu'il va quand
même assez loin on comprend assez bien
que ce n'était pas volontaire de sa part
mais qui est arrivé tout est assumé à
placer des hold up benjo on appelait ça
des réquisitions volontaire et 5 points
le documentaire les roses ne fera sans
doute pas d'unanimité mais il fera
certainement réfléchir
le film prendra l'affiché le 21 ou ici
louis philippe ouimet radio-canada
mourir